[VIDEO GAME BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Google
Cloud Natural Language
reveals the structure
and meaning of text
by offering powerful
machine learning models
in an easy-to-use REST API.
You can use it to extract
information about places,
events, and much more.
You can also use it to
understand sentiment
about your product
on social media,
or parse intent from customer
conversations happening
in a call center
or messaging app.
You can analyze text
uploaded in your request
or integrate with
your document storage
on Google Cloud Storage.
Let's try this API
with this sentence.
Google, headquartered
in Mountain View,
unveiled the new Android phone
at the Consumer Electronics
Show.
Sundar Pichai said
in his keynote
that users love their
new Android phones.
All right, now let's
see what information
the API has given us.
We can see that it shows the
entities in the sentence,
the sentiment, syntax,
and even classified
which categories the
sentence could belong in.
You don't have just English
to work with, either.
Cloud Natural Language
enables you to easily analyze
text in multiple languages,
including English,
Spanish, Japanese, Chinese--
both simplified
and traditional--
French, German, Italian,
Korean, and Portuguese.
In just 40 minutes you'll learn
how to use this powerful API.
So let's head over to Qwiklabs.
In this lab you'll
create an API key,
create an entity
analysis request,
and then call the
Natural Language API.
This self-paced lab is
part of the Baseline--
Data, ML, and AI
quest on Qwiklabs.
Completing all the
labs in this quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.